coral reefs occupy less than a quarter
of 1% of the ocean
get our home to a quarter of all marine
life each coral is comprised of hundreds
to thousands of individual polyps all
attached to a rock-hard skeleton that
they form but exactly how corals
construct these stony skeletons has long
been debated is it a straightforward
chemical process of reflects
environmental conditions or the coral
polyps exert some control through their
biology to answer this question
researchers studied stylophora pissed
Alana a widespread stony coral found in
the Indian and Pacific Oceans using
high-tech imaging they found that corals
secrete acid rich proteins which
encourage the precipitation of a form of
calcium carbonate known as Eragon I each
day the corals secrete enough of these
proteins to leave more than 5 microns
with stoney coating if you watch the
coral growing in a tank at this rate
you'd see at least one millimeter of
growth in 250 days researchers also
found that these acid rich proteins can
function within a relatively wide pH
range and may be able to adapt to new
conditions as the ocean home becomes
more acidic due to climate change
because of their control over the
protein secretion and the ability to
respond or not different conditions
these findings strongly suggest that
coral skeleton building is largely
biological coral reefs can still be
affected by other factors such as rising
ocean temperatures and nutrient
pollution but at least for now we know
corals are the captain of their own ship
[Music]
Oh
[Music]